this is Startalk we're back on Startalk
this is the how tweet it is part
I love how tweeted it I got bill with me
here we just looking over tweets I
posted and just find out what is Bill's
reaction what was I thinking that
anybody else reacted people wonder the
Edit what was he think there You've when
he tweeted here it is so here after I
saw the movie interstellar I had a whole
barrage of tweets yep commenting I'm
highlighting the physics of it this sort
of thing so here's one mysteries of
interstellar can't imagine a future
where escaping earth via a wormhole is a
better plan than just fixing earth well
this is what made it literally
incredible for me oh really I mean I
never you know as we say in comedy if
you buy the premise you buy the bit I
didn't buy the premise the premise I
mean I know people love the interstellar
I know people that saw it twice well why
would you agree that we could have
blight on the crops but my issue was not
that there wouldn't be Bly but that why
is it easier to launch a spaceship
through a wormhole and go live on a moon
of Saturn where balls fall up I don't
want to give it too much away but it
really is an extraordinary and I think
it gets bad well they weren't on a moon
of Saturn Saturn was where the wormhole
was that got him to another place a
movie where were they oh yeah I don't
know where they were yeah yeah okay so
okay uh anyways troublesome anyway the
physics that we all know radically
changed but there is an entire book
published alongside the release of the
movie called the physics of inter-cell
Howard - written by my colleague my man
you know you know who uh yeah Kip Thorne
Kip Thorne he was saw Kip Thorne a
professor of physics at Caltech a
specialist in cosmology and Einstein Ian
relativity and he was not only science
advisor he was also one of the executive
producers oh good yeah yeah okay I'm
just saying I'm not gonna fly around for
72 relativistic years years with Anne
Hathaway's character without a little
more something some that's something and
then let me ask you this why are we
driving the corn is going to sustain all
of us through some sort of genetic
modification you get all your nutrition
out of corn
vitamin C the selenium that whatever was
in the beer that he was drinking yeah
okay but yeah you make beer out of corn
why don't we drive through the field for
10 minutes and then get the
indian-origin a drone spacecraft and
nothing was ever done just drop a loose
end a MacGuffin like what's going on it
was three hours a hours my only point of
the tweet was dryly right we can earth
people this is where we make our stand
this is what I say to everybody this is
the battle for you it is Battlefield
Earth this tradition of just go moving
you've trashed an area just move to a
different area just expand just
mistletoe it's okay when you're on earth
because it's still earth yeah and you
can breathe right but we're gonna reach
a point as humankind we're just leaving
the earth is not an option we're going
to have to be better stewards of the
environment and dare I say it Neil the
Bill Nye has spoken change the world as
he backs away three feet from the mic
not wanting to send the audio levels
into the red it's it's a radio truth
this is what this has been how to eat it
is on Startalk join the conversation on
twitter at star talk radio I'm your host
and you'll deGrasse Tyson bidding you to
keep looking up this is Startalk
you